vorteil für beiden in mehreren us
bundesstaaten wird immer noch ausgezählt
herausforderer beiden überholt in
wichtigen staaten amtsinhaber jump
kampfansage live im fernsehen der
us-präsident spricht von wahlbetrug
mehrere tv-sender steigen daraufhin aus
der übertragung aus und corona und die
dunkelziffer eine studie aus münchen
zeigt jetzt dass es wohl deutlich mehr
infizierte gibt als bislang bekannt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen christian otto ist auch dabei
für den sport mit top fußball guten
abend auch drei tage nach der us wahl
bleibt das rennen um die präsidentschaft
eine zitterpartie aber eine auf der
zielgeraden ein sieg des herausforderers
joe biden wird immer wahrscheinlicher
denn er liegt jetzt in vier von sechs
noch ausstehenden bundesstaaten vor den
job und zwar in arizona nevada georgia
und pennsylvania allein der sieg in
pennsylvania würde beiden über die
notwendige 270 wahlmänner marke helfen
am wahltag lag trump hier noch mit mehr
als 600.000 stimmen vor beiden dann
begann die auszählung der stimmen von
briefwählern und bürgern die vor dem
wahltag ihr votum abgegeben hatten
sie sind grundsätzlich mehrheitlich joe
biden wähler heute morgen überholt er
donald trump und liegt im moment wird
fast 9000 stimmen vorn ähnliches bild in
georgia trump führt am wahltag mit mehr
als 104.000 stimmen beiden holt auf und
hat derzeit rund 1600 stimmen mehr
heike slansky auch in dieser nacht
stehen sich trump und beiden anhänger
unversöhnlich gegenüber wie hier in
detroit michigan
beiden wurde in diesem bundesstaat
bereits zum gewinner erklärt doch trump
fans wittern wahlbetrug sie haben
betrogen das ist kein faires ergebnis
wurde manipuliert
wir müssen flagge zeigen gegen tan das
ist doch nicht okay noch in dieser nacht
gibt ein weiterer staat zu gunsten von
beiden im konservativen georgia hat
jetzt der herausforderer die nase vorn
so knapp dass vielleicht neu ausgezählt
werden muss auch in pennsylvania liegt
beiden vorne aus dem weißen haus
verfolgt er den wahlkrimi twittert
unaufhörlich bis er einsam die bühne
betritt wahlbetrug so behauptet er
wiederholt ohne belege allen wichtigen
staaten lagen wir vorne und plötzlich
wurden unsere zahlen wie von zauberhand
heimlich immer weniger
so stehlen sie die wahl sie versuchen zu
betrügen das können wir nicht zulassen
mehrere fernsehsender unterbrechen die
live übertragung für die behauptungen
des präsidenten gebe es keine beweise
im bundesstaat delaware meldet sich joe
biden zu wort er ist zuversichtlich und
versucht seine landsleute zu beruhigen
wir haben keinen zweifel daran wenn
alles ausgezählt ist dass die senatorin
harris und ich die sieger sein werden
ich bitte alle ruhig zu bleiben
der prozess funktioniert die stimmen
werden vollständig ausgezählt bald
werden wir mehr wissen
tag drei nach der us-wahl immer noch
kein offizielles ergebnis es bleibt eine
zitterpartie
katrin eigendorf ist für uns in
pennsylvania dem möglicherweise
entscheidenden bundesstaat wenn joe
biden hier gewinnt hat er es geschafft
katrin wie nah ist er den sieg er gerät
immer näher an den sieg heran es ist
jetzt so dass der stand heute abend der
ist das nur noch neun dass das er mit
9000 stimmen führt also man muss sagen
in den letzten vier stunden hat sich der
trend eigentlich kontinuierlich für joe
biden entwickelt das wichtige was wir
hier noch sehen müssen dass vor allem
die großen städte wie hier
philadelphia aber auch pittsburgh noch
ein bisschen hinten dran sind bei der
auszählung und dass das nochmal dazu
beitragen kann dass sich das bild weiter
für beiden verschiebt in diese städte
diese großen städte sind hochburgen der
demokraten
alle warten hier gespannt darauf dass
die auszählungen ihren endspurt geht
wann das wirklich passiert das ist im
moment die große frage
informationen live aus philadelphia
dankeschön katrin eigendorf donald trump
will die drohende niederlage auf keinen
fall akzeptieren noch in der wahlnacht
erklärte er sich vorzeitig zum sieger
und spricht dann immer wieder von
wahlbetrug obwohl es dafür keinerlei
anzeichen gibt er will die
stimmauszählung gerichtlich stoppen
lassen weil die demokraten ihm angeblich
den sieg mit illegalen stimmt
über die strategie des präsidenten ist
ramms erster auftritt nach der wahlnacht
eine brandrede
er greift die amerikanische demokratie
an das prinzip jede stimme zählt die
stimmen der briefwähler will er nicht
werten lassen denn sie stehen er bei den
demokraten ohne beweise vorzulegen
spricht er von betrug die briefwahl
zerstört unser system ein korruptes
system es macht die menschen korrupt
auch wenn sie es eigentlich nicht sind
aber es ist so einfach auf diesen kurs
begleitend am seine söhne und seine
anwälte sie hetzen von pressekonferenz
zur pressekonferenz und verteidigen die
klagen gegen die noch offenen staaten
und sie rufen zum äußersten auf das
beste für amerikas zukunft wäre wenn
donald trump in den totalen krieg zieht
wegen dieser wahl um all den betrug all
die schummelei aufzudecken von
republikanern äußert sich die erste
reihe nicht kritik nur von denen die
nicht auf trump angewiesen sind die
anderen sind an seiner seite
ich stehe zu trump denn erst dann zu mir
er ist der grund warum wir eine
senatsmehrheit haben die demokraten
stehen dem präsidenten eine wahl und
seinen 60 millionen wählern
stoppt die auszählung rufen trance
anhänger vor den zehn stationen er
untergräbt ihr vertrauen in diese wahl
riskant amerika ist das land das stolz
das recht seiner bürger auf waffen
verteidigt das aber wird gefährlich wenn
die politische elite des landes nicht
für einen friedlichen übergang von einem
präsidenten zum nächsten eintritt der
wahl gibt das team von joe biden bekannt
im falle eines sieges sei man bereit
kommt auch zwangsweise aus dem weißen
haus zu eskortieren
auch das ergebnis von arizona steht noch
aus auch hier führt joe biden 93 prozent
der stimmen sind ausgezählt davon gehen
50 prozent an joe biden 48,6 an donald
trump seine anhänger glauben noch an den
wahlsieg und heizen die stimmung weiter
auf aus phoenix
manfred schadt den zweiten abend in
folge ziehen donald trump anhänger vor
die wahlbehörde in phoenix einige von
ihnen schwer bewaffnet sie wollen nicht
glauben dass ihr präsident die wahl
verloren haben könnte hat schon gewonnen
er hat gewonnen nachdem sie die
stimmauszählung eingestellt haben das
haben sie gemacht damit er nicht die 270
wahlmänner stimmen erreicht die
demokraten wollen uns unser land
wegnehmen sie stehen diese wahl
es könnte der tag kommen wenn sich die
leute versammeln und ihre rechte
verteidigen müssen und das könnte auch
zu einem physischen krieg kommen
die stimmung in arizona hat sich spürbar
auf einige geschäfte stellen sich auf
ausschreitungen ein
die meisten bürger wünschen sich ein
ende der politischen spaltung obmann
republikaner ist oder demokrat das
wichtigste ist respekt zu haben und eine
gemeinsame basis von fakten und realität
dazu müssen wir zurückkommen minütige
werk gedanken das stadtbild von phoenix
dominieren die anhänger von donald trump
von den demokraten ist wenig zu sehen
nur ein mann traut sich und hält dagegen
sie haben waffen und sie wollen sie
benutzen
man bringt keine waffe mit wenn man
miteinander reden will und zeigt sich
herum
das ist nicht richtig sie sind hier um
die leute einzuschüchtern
der hier den tisch die trump anhänger
wollen weiter vor die wahlbehörde ziehen
eine niederlage ihres präsidenten werden
sie wohl nicht ohne weiteres akzeptieren
wollen wir unseren washington
korrespondenten in athen essen dazu wir
haben es gehört immer donald trump ist
immer wieder öl ins feuer sein sohn ruf
zum totalen krieg auf wie gefährlich ist
dieses verhalten
das ist natürlich brandgefährlich weil
viele seiner anhänger 100 prozent an das
glauben was donald trump ihnen sagt auch
wenn es falsch behauptungen und lügen
sind selbst die republikanischen
regierungen in staaten wie arizona und
georgia sagen ganz klar dass bei dieser
wahl bisher alles mit rechten dingen
zugegangen ist und vor dem hintergrund
ist jetzt eine situation entstanden wo
es eigentlich aus der republikanischen
partei an
führer bräuchte die dem präsidenten im
weißen haus hier hinter uns sagen dass
er die wahl mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
verloren hat das eher beruhigend auch
auf seine anhänger einwirken muss diese
republikanischen anführer sind derzeit
nicht in sicht vielleicht halten sie
sich offen was bei den klagen
herauskommt joe biden selber hat hören
wie er hinter den kulissen kontakt zu
den republikanern aufgenommen und er
wird sich heute abend in einer rede an
die nation wenden
im fernsehen und auch da versuchen
beschwichtigend auf alle einzuwirken und
ihnen zu sagen er wäre ein präsident für
alle amerikaner dann geschehen für diese
einschätzung aus washington e motive der
präsident untergräbt den demokratischen
prozess wie lange macht seine partei das
noch mit das ist ein thema im zdf
spezial direkt nach dieser sendung um 19
uhr 20 und auch online bleiben sie mit
der zdf heute app immer informiert im
live blog gibt es jederzeit alle
wichtigen entwicklungen kommen wir zum
zweiten großen thema corona die
neuinfektionen steigen weiter rasant an
nach angaben des robert-koch-instituts
haben sich innerhalb eines tages 21.500
sechs menschen mit dem virus angesteckt
166 sind im zusammenhang mit koma
gestorben
anlass zur hoffnung gibt allerdings der
re produktionswert der ging seit anfang
der woche von 1,07 auf 0,70 zurück das
bedeutet ein infizierter steckt
statistisch gesehen weniger als eine
person an der aire wert bildet das
infektionsgeschehen vor etwa zehn tagen
ab wie viele menschen haben sich mit
corona infiziert ohne es zu wissen das
ist nach wie vor eine der großen fragen
in dieser pandemie eine neue studie gibt
jetzt hinweise auf die dunkelziffer in
münchen
forscher untersuchten im frühjahr 5300
zufällig ausgewählte bürger auf
antikörper das ergebnis 1,8 prozent
welche hatten also eine infektion das
sind deutlich mehr als damals offiziell
in münchen gemeldet waren
petra neubauer hat details jan kunkel
will helfen mehr klarheit zu schaffen
deshalb nimmt er an der großen münchner
corona studie teil
die ersten ergebnisse haben ihn
überrascht das erstaunliche war dass ich
antikörper hatte meine frau dagegen
nicht und wir beide aber keine symptome
hatten wie jan kunkel haben viele also
gar nicht bemerkt dass sie infiziert und
somit ansteckend sind
diese hohe dunkelziffer ist eines der
großen probleme
wir haben festgestellt dass das etwa
drei von vier fällen waren das liegt
daran dass viele patienten eben auch
keine symptome hatten oder eben auch gar
nicht getestet werden konnten weil die
test kapazität nicht zu verfügung
gestanden haben tatsächlich waren im
frühjahr in münchen vier mal so viele
menschen infiziert wie offiziell
gemeldet für die studie hatten
medizinstudenten von märz bis juni in
rund 3000 haushalten blutproben genommen
trotz der hohen dunkelziffer sei man
meilenweit entfernt von einer
durchsuchung die wissenschaftler haben
zudem festgestellt dass die
sterblichkeitsrate in zusammenhang mit
corona um ein vielfaches höher ist als
bei der saisonalen grippe
die studie ist insofern interessant und
relevant weise zum einen über einen
relativ langen zeitraum patienten sich
angeschaut haben also wir reden über
einen drei monats zeitraum
und es ist in einer großen deutschen
metropole durchgeführt worden
während andere er in sogenannten hot
spots durchgeführt worden sind
der erste lockdown im frühjahr mit all
seinen kontakt beschränkungen hat
übrigens eine deutliche wirkung gezeigt
und die infektionszahlen sinken lassen
auch dass sein ergebnis der münchner
studie
die schulen sollen unbedingt offen
bleiben dass es erklärtes ziel von bund
und ländern dafür gelten auf dem
schulgelände strenge abstands und
hygieneregeln in schulbussen und zügen
ist es aber schlicht unmöglich diese
regeln einzuhalten denn dort ist es oft
rappelvoll
der verband der verkehrsunternehmen
fordert deshalb einen gestaffelten
beginn des unterrichts an alle da hat
mehr gedränge an der haltestelle
gedränge in bus und bahn
so sieht der alltag vieler schülerinnen
und schüler in deutschland aussehen
corona zeiten ist die fahrt zur schule
zusätzlich belastend also wo ich steige
geht es noch aber dann steigen so viele
eines wirklich welche stehen bleiben
müssen draußen und nicht mehr
hinzukommen
und ja ist es einfach eng und man fühlt
sich auch nicht so wohl eben wegen
corona vor allem in großstädten und
ballungsräumen wird es morgens im
nahverkehr besonders an schüler und
pendler sind gleichzeitig unterwegs
abstand halten unmöglich insgesamt wird
uns das in extrem helfen wenn man da sei
es der schulen die anfangszeiten
entzerrt das würde auf einen schlag bei
uns 20 prozent mehr kapazitäten in den
fahrzeugen bringen und damit eben auch
mehr platz aber gestaltete anfangszeiten
würden den komplexen schulbetrieb ändern
schwierig vor allem wenn lehrkräfte
krank oder in quarantäne sind außerdem
hätten sich die schulen schon massiv
umgestellt mit lüften masken pflicht und
eingeschränktem sportunterricht es ist
im moment eine phase die wirklich an die
substanz von einer schule geht und dann
empfinde ich diese forderung schon fast
als frech hier jetzt zu sagen die schule
muss ich noch mal da bewegen dann heißt
es natürlich auch dass das normale
familienleben liebers moment kennen die
stattfinden kann
das heißt man hat keine festen zeit mehr
muss auch wieder drüber nachdenken
inwieweit bräuchen betreuung
gegebenenfalls im vormittags bereich vor
allem für familien mit jüngeren kindern
entstünden betreuungslücke schüler von
ganztagsschulen kämen wiederum abends
deutlich später nach hause
der bundesrat hat heute getagt und
gleich mehrere wichtige dinge
beschlossen die vertreter der länder
stimmten zum schutz der umwelt einem
verbot verschiedene einweg artikel zu ab
juli 2021 sind unter anderem plastik
trinkhalme besteck oder wattestäbchen
nicht mehr erlaubt das wachstum des
bundestags soll ausgebremst werden durch
eine deckelung bei ausgleichs und
überhangmandaten und die bezugsdauer des
kurzarbeitergeldes wird in der korona
krise verlängert auf bis zu 24 monate
die bundesanwaltschaft hat eine
mutmaßliche linksextremisten
leipzig festnehmen lassen der vorwurf
die 25 jährige soll als mitglied einer
kriminellen vereinigung überfälle auf
angehörige der politisch rechten szene
vorbereitet und kommentiert haben
dabei seien die angegriffenen mit
schlagstöcken reizvoll und faustschlägen
verletzt worden
die bundesanwaltschaft geht davon aus
dass die linksextreme gruppe ungefähr
zehn mitglieder umfasst und auch die
ermittlungen nach dem islamistischen
anschlag in wien laufen auch hochtouren
und weisen auch nach deutschland
am vormittag hat das bundeskriminalamt
wohnungen von fünf jungen männern in
mehreren bundesländern durchsucht sie
seien nicht tatverdächtig sollen aber
teilweise verbindungen zu dem
österreichischen attentäter gehabt haben
festnahmen gab es nicht
es war ein verbrechen das im letzten
dezember entsetzen auslöste ein
familienvater war am nikolausabend in
augsburg von einem damals 17 jährigen
niedergeschlagen worden
das opfer ein feuerwehrmann starb an
einer tödlichen bedrohung
das landgericht augsburg hat jetzt sein
urteil gefällt eine jugendstrafe von
vier jahren und sechs monaten wegen
körperverletzung mit todesfolge
der verurteilte hatte auf nothilfe
plädiert er habe einen freund schützen
wollen den der 49-jährige gestoßen habe
so und jetzt hoffentlich christin bei
dir auch etwas erfreuliches von der
euroleague europa die europa league
genau die bundesliga lockt dort die
bühne
zwei vereine zwei siege beide als
tabellenführer nach drei spieltagen mit
besten chancen aufs weiterkommen
hoffenheim nach dem 5 0 gegen die
tschechen von slovan liberec und
leverkusen nach dem 4 2 bei hapoel beer
scheva inn israel leon bailey ist
leverkusens matchwinner der jamaikaner
füllt die lücke im sturmzentrum immer
besser aus zunächst hält er einfach
drauf die führung schon nach fünf
minuten
aber der schönste treffer des abends
gelingt ihm eltern akku lasse
niederländer in diensten des
israelischen pokalsiegers der stever ein
schwindelerregender slalomlauf durch die
leverkusener abwehr das 2 2 1 etwas für
fußball genießt beim stande von 2 2 11
minuten vor schluss geht dorthin wo es
wehtut kopfball in bedrängnis zum 3 2
endstand 4 2 für leverkusen drei punkte
mitgebracht von 3000 kilometer
entfernten auswärts spielt da lässt sich
auch ein leichter brummschädel
verkraften
nach dem torreichen gala auftritten der
champions league morgen abend das
gipfeltreffen in der bundesliga siebte
spieltag borussia dortmund gegen bayern
münchen der zweite empfängt den
punktgleichen ersten erzählt nur 1 der
sieg der siegeswille bei seiner
mannschaft sei top sagt hansi flick der
bayern coach lässt sich sogar zu einer
art liebeserklärung hinreißen ist schon
herausragend was wir in den letzten
wochen und monaten einfach gezeigt haben
kompliment an die mannschaft aber sie
weiß natürlich auch dass man gegen
dortmund einfach schauen muss dass man
möglichst wenig fehler macht und
natürlich möglichst viele tore dafür ist
robert lewandowski zuständig der top
torjäger der liga mit bereits zehn
treffer nach fünf spielen
sein gegenüber bei den dortmundern
oerlinghausen zwölf jahre jünger als
lewandowski der 20 jährige zuletzt
bärenstark wir haben schon
selbstvertrauen wohl morgen alles in die
waagschale werfen um dieses spiel auch
zu gewinnen ob der angeschlagene
abwehrchef mats hummels seine mannschaft
bei der säge mission unterstützen kann
entscheidet sich morgen früh und morgen
abend dann natürlich ausführlich alles
zum gipfel 23.30 im aktuellen
sportstudio und jetzt zum schluss noch
schnell was zum schmunzeln denn mitunter
können hochzeiten herrliche doppelnamen
hervorbringen so wie bei diesem paar in
großbritannien kurz vor dem lockdown
heiratete tilly christmas ihren liebsten
tieren liegt das ergebnis der kommentare
braut ich habe den perfekten ehemann der
zufällig auch noch den perfekten
nachnamen hat das muss man auch die ehe
perfekt werden als ich geht's beim
wetter weiter mehr dazu hat gleich
resten technik christian sievers freut
sich auf sie im heute journal um 10 18
zdf spezial und wir freuen uns wenn sie
mal einen schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen zum wetter erinnern
sie sich noch an den eisberg der in der
antarktis abgebrochenes 68 vor drei
jahren und er ist immer noch unterwegs
und bedroht jetzt süd georgien dass es
diese insel hier und sie sehen die insel
fast genauso groß wie der eisberg der
160 kilometer lang ist und 46 kilometer
breit
wir kommen zu anderen eisigen aussichten
in deutschland wird es in der kommenden
nacht frostig werden im südosten dazu
bildet sich nebel im südwesten ansonsten
gibt es kompakte wolken im norden und
die temperaturen ja die geben bis auf
minus 5 grad zurück hier also frostig
und hier kann es auch glatt werden
deutlich milder an der ostsee mit neun
grad morgen im tagesverlauf muss erstmal
der nebel verschwinden und dann wird es
sonnig im süden kann der nebel längere
zeit zu bleiben aber sonst sie sehen es
verbreitet sonnenschein bei temperaturen
bis 17 grad im westen deutschlands und
im süden an der donau um 5 grad
die kommenden tage sehen eigentlich
ähnlich aus nach nebel sonnenschein bei
temperaturen von fünf bis 18 grad
dienstag nicht mehr ganz so mild damit
ein schöner abend